[Aplausos]
e aí a gente manda tudo bem com vocês
agora estão assim porque eu sou um
atacante em campo é mas sei que foi um
presente de um fã olhei lá em fortaleza
no santos eu conheço o negócio ganhou um
urso bem mais o cheiroso ver foto grey
cá eu liguei em bayeux e três carros mas
já saiu quatro aces e ganhou três
olha zerado lacrado nunca quem não
comprou só por jogar comigo tcheco que
já viu jogar só que a pessoa já ganhou
18 acabou bem e cadernos publicados e
gozo adesivo colegas ficar e agora vê o
melhor longa e uma espada de um fã mano
o que nunca é uma tentação do tipo de
redução da festa lá em fortaleza está o
cara o cara que me deu é da loja
bancário que também que na descrição do
vídeo tenha sido facebook longe bancar
você vai lá curtir ou comenta eu vi a
espada do inaceitável que eu estava
andando em bogotá pelo choro aquele cara
que canta a música cavaleiros onde ele é
um cara no chão oi foi me levando a loja
era atencioso e do nada o cara me deu me
deu essa espada e eu sou apaixonada por
espada então da visitado pelo facebook
da orc embaixo daquela moral
muito obrigado para que deus está aqui
que [ __ ] era meu sonho é uma agente é
que eu acho que vai ser perfeito a matar
mais pessoas e muito obrigada pessoal de
fortalecimento recebeu muito bem tanto
no teatro como lá na galera do sangue e
tower que tirar foto comigo na rua no
shopping em qualquer lugar muito
obrigada pra mim muito obrigado
só fala mais uma coisa para você está
rolando em um concurso chamado chorei ao
ar que é mais ou menos como se fosse
tipo mostra na internet ligado e eu
estou participando na categoria vídeo
blog eu tô acho que o oitavo lugar
também o primeiro link da inscrição tem
assim volte em você vai clicar nele vai
aparecer uma parada lá
apareceu uma coisa é você desce um
pouquinho é assim e não me meti em
subidas onu na categoria vídeo nome
porque brincar três pontinhos na frente
dodô fez pouquinho na frente dos três
pontinhos e coloca assim porque ele é
bom porque não há destino porque não sei
o que lá e clique em tuitaço da votação
pelo twitter tá então você entra no seu
twitter que tal você clica no link está
aqui na descrição do vídeo o primeiro
link é você desce um pouquinho escreve
porque você quer que eu ganhei você
clica intuito dar ele vai dar
automaticamente aquela pitada lá e você
automaticamente já votou em mim tudo e
você só pode votar um veio então vou
falar pra dar aquela moral e à noite
e aí a gente vai tornar tudo bom vocês
comigo está tudo bem
é claro que tá só porque que o canal
passou de toninho incrito entanto sabe
que há 600 mil inscritos
eita galera está sendo mais tranqüilo
que tem 600 mil escrituras 600 mil
inscritos e fala assim meu irmão esse
cara aqui eu apoio é 600 mil pessoas
imagina que vá longe é 600 mil pessoas
para o meu desse menino o menino bom
então muito obrigado a você está escrito
o canal muito obrigado no cargo é
obrigado muito obrigado do fundo do meu
coração é a a agradecer os fãs que todo
mundo vai ficar ali com pena dele não
vai mais ela mas eu fico muito feliz em
saber que tem tanta gente que bota fé no
menino que faz o vídeo não pousam quarto
desarrumado usa um boné e idiota no meio
vídeo toda vida e vocês estão sempre
aqui toda quarta e todos assistindo todo
o vídeo aqui que eu não gostei da
comentando se inscrever no canal [ __ ]
é muito bom isso é muito bom você não
sabe o quanto é gratificante pra mim
isso não trouxer do fundo do coração
muito obrigado
ele vai todo mundo olha vamos lá eu já
falei pra cá embora falar o que é do
vídeo é porque é o seguinte agora tá
começando o carnaval não é carnaval
naquela época maravilhosa em todas as
pessoas se reúne para louvar na cena
jazz 2 que todas as vidas seja protegido
nossa vida não confundir carnaval
naquela época todo mundo se reúne e
vamos lá atrás o director de estudos
quero ver em tempo treinando por tem
tenha claudia leitte ivete sangalo que
aquela banda lá né chiclete com banana
que é uma coisa que às vezes me faz
parar a esse pensar filosofar né meu
deus será que desgraçado da minha vida
ia parar a comer chiclete com banana
porque é uma mistura bem assim externa
que só assim banana cuzco já dá aquela
coisa assim a banana daquela coisa
ensino agora chiclete com banana assim ó
ano no bar não que a banda esperto não
seria ruim longe em agora um monte de
bem que eu posso estar a falar de novo é
que no meu endereço acho que o cara que
botou o nome chiclete com banana devia
ser amiga da minha mãe e meu filho
nasceu vou botar o nome de edil estava a
lançar se para botar na minha banda
chiclete com banana aidan isso aí ínfima
o assunto nem sequer falaram é que no
carnaval eu não sei que doença que as
pessoas têm que a pessoa não quer ficar
bonita pra ela mesma sempre quer ficar
muito com as outras pessoas chega o
carnaval partiu dele a pessoa passando
toda depósito como em todo tipo de
porcaria nunca naval e para ficar bonito
que o tek tam sa no reboleira sansa tem
ser então rebolation o ruim de gente que
mora na bahia que é o seguinte
geralmente quem marca o carnaval não
começa a falar em setembro em agosto a
pensão que marca o carnaval ela passa o
antológico média junto do natal
coisas boas da galinha tudo que tem na
casa das tias pela viagem passou na casa
de outra tive o que fazer com o mais
gostoso na casa da avó porque em casa de
voz em sintonia em casa a gente fala mãe
tô com fome ela fazem feijão na
geladeira lá esquenta e como cada um de
vós está com fome ela faltou me ouvissem
reais balançar só enquanto permite fazer
amor um golo do braga chega eu fiquei
aqui é o marty bowen um ato muito o cm a
bola pensa tanto a comida do nec um ano
antes ela aponta o pé de manga para o
dito falar e até mano quanto comer
menino vai cumprir serviço não caro
demora só espaço até sem pagar na
catraca do ano de tomar que tá agora tô
de volta da casa da avó era obrigado a
pagar três passagens pelo olímpico duro
aí a pessoa espera e vez de malhar bem
um vai marcar a semana do carnaval na
porta do camarim
oscar já maria falando essa que pediria
ajuda chega a perguntar e aí papai noel
é é uma harmonia do samba até aquela
mulher que quer ficar com a bunda bonita
aí uma semana de carnaval ela percebe
que tem celulite engraçado antoun ela
perceber e eu vou perceber um antes do
carnaval porque sou gostosa demais e uma
mulher que vai malhar o carnaval é pela
sempre tem aquela amiga que fala assim
como a mulher que bom né mulher que tem
essa onda tão bonita sem celulite neto
não sabe o quanto é agraciada por deus
mulher eu quero que tudo seja muito
feliz e quero que morra de felicidade ou
lê só que na cabeça dela assim como a
desgraça dessa se acha que só que ser
ocultadas encerada com melhor sabor do
mundo é bonita é bonita quanto mais eu
não sei que é tudo anticoncepcional
aparece anticoncepcional aí fica aquela
briga dura para gente é gente por favor
mas muito antes do carnaval
foi malhar maria paz aonde meio fica
melhor pra você você se dirige uma
melhor você fica melhor
o carnaval aqui hoje porque a rua do
hotel sem pagar as peças não dar certo
eu fiz um vídeo dias atrás só da
academia que eu seguir a dica do gaúcho
andré que esse canal aqui se quiser eu
já mudei bastante ó já mudei um pouco da
banda tato com o braço um pouco maior
com menos gordura do b que está um pouco
mais definidos e eu estou começando o
frango e toma estava certa de que estou
seguindo para a mulher que quer se
livrar da celulite do canal que esse
vídeo aqui também caso você queira ver
quando eu falei me atendeu muito bem pô
só que agradecer e está dando certo e
agora vou ter que comprar uma máquina
vou marcar gols e depois vou comprar uma
margem para falhar em casa tá então você
clique aqui para se inscrever no final
do ano e caso você queira pegar uma né
pra malhar direito bem antes do carnaval
e tal apesar que já está muito em cima
mas eu acho linda tarde e agora pensei
essas pessoas que mais amo carnaval acho
que não dá jeito eu quero você comente
aqui embaixo é coisa sobre você quer
saber o que você quer na sua meta por
seu corpo neste ano é que você quer
emagrecer se quer ficar mais gols e quer
ficar mais forte é o que quer dizer que
eu quero saber como é que embaixo eu vou
ler todos os comentários possível
responder a um rapaz eu vou aproveitar
bem o seguinte você pode notar que ela é
um pouco grande né abc espada
sabe aquela vai parar se não clicarem
gostei o doido não dói é certo que não
gostei ajuda nós estamos ficando gostei
de dançar anos ao total
eu não te fala nada noite diego e quando
antes era tão falando eu treino porque
para nós se a primeira vez citasse a
primeira vez está assistindo um vídeo no
canal só que quem escreveu e aquela
coisa certa no twitter e no facebook
segue estagnada e ai é nós